ليس امام هؤلاء النازحين سوى الاشجار
يحتمون بها من حراره صيف ساخن عرفت به
بورسودان على ساحل البحر الاحمر
فاطمه نزحت من الخرطوم مع طفليها الى بورت
سودان فوجدت نفسها هنا مثل كثيرين على
رصيف شاطئ المدينه
يمر الوقت عليها بطيئا ومقلقا فالحصول على
الغذاء ليس هاجسها اليوميه الوحيد بل هو
حاجتها ايضا الى رعايه صحيه وهي في شهرها
الاخير من الحمل
والحرب اشتردنا من اهلنا وخلينا بيوتنا
اذان الوضع الحاصل كله
اما محمد فهو اثيوبي يعيش الخرطوم منذ 30
عاما نالت منه بعض الشظايا عندما تعرض
رسوله للقصف اثناء وجوده ديفنانه قصته
تكشف عما يعانيه الكثيرون من سكان الخرطوم
خصوصا من يعيش منهم في مناطق المواجهات
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
يلا جاءت ضرب كبير
انتشر بيت دمروا الحمد لله اولادي ما
كانوا قاعدين جوه الساعه ثمانيه سبان
ضربته
عالجت بالليل الساعه عشره
مغادره النازحين للخرطوم اصبحت في الاونه
الاخيره محفوفه بالمخاطر وفيها الكثير من
المجازفه
عشان اجي هنا عانيت لانه كان اصلا ما عنده
قروش كاش
ومشيت
عشان اركبك
وكل ما نمشي انا من
كان في بيت ولد عمي في حته اسمها حطاب
البحري عشان اصلا مين البري كان تعبت
لكل ناجحين قصته التي لم تنتهي فصولها بعد
فالحرب تترك في نفوس ضحاياها اوجاعا لا
حصر لها وقد ضاعف من ذلك تعطل معظم
الخدمات في البلاد معاناه النازحين في
السودان تفوق بكثير ما يقدم اليهم من
مساعدات انسانيه ومع الزيادهم تتعاظم
حاجتهم الى الغذاء والماء والدواء
والرعايه الصحيه والنفسيه ايضا بعد تجارب
مريره عاشها كثيرون منهم في الخرطوم
واثناء عمليه النزوح حمدي البكاري الجزيره
بورت سودان